Traductor: aster orozco
Revisor: Eduardo Sierra
Balanceándose a través del desértico
suelo Australiano
esta ornitorrinco hembra busca
agua fresca
a través de los años, una severa sequia
convirtió ríos y arroyos
en simples chorritos.
Ella apenas sobrevivió
y fue incapaz de reproducirse.
Podría el siguiente año traer un cambio
en la suerte?
Es otoño y finalmente gotas de lluvia
caen del cielo.
Dentro de unos días, la ornitorrinco
encuentra un rio y empieza a cazar.
Sus patas palmeadas la impulsan
y su abrigo a prueba de agua
atrapa el calor cerca de su cuerpo.
Bajo el agua, ella siente su alrededor
con su cola pico de pato,
la cual esta equipada con casi 40,000
electrorreceptores.
Esto le permite detectar hasta la
mas minima señal eléctrica
viniendo de nervios y músculos
de un camarón.
Ella lo convierte en comida rápida.
Y una vez que sube de nuevo
a tierra para construir una madriguera,
camina en una posición de lagarto,
sus patas moviéndose horizontalmente
hacia su espina.
El ornitorrinco tiene muchas rarezas.
Como un monotrema, es parte del mas
antiguo linaje de mamíferos vivos hoy dia.
Por ende, tiene un mezcla curiosa de
rasgos mamíferos, aviares y reptiles,
lo cual se refleja en su genoma.
Por ejemplo, los mamíferos tienen
un par de cromosomas que definen su sexo,
Pero el ornitorrinco tiene cinco,
que se asemejan mas a los de las aves.
Esperemos que ella los pueda utilizar.
Ella recupera su fuerza y,
así como el invierno se vuelve primavera,
es hora de aparearse.
Pero no puede criar a sus crías aquí.
La tierra ha comenzado a ser deforestada,
haciendo que la orilla se erosione,
Por lo que, va rio arriba
y se queda en un claro, profundo estanque
protegido por un eucalipto rojo.
De repente, un ruido espanta a las aves
de la maleza y un zorro aparece.
Estos depredadores amenazan
a los ornitorrincos
desde que fueron introducidos
a Australia por los europeos en 1855.
El zorro no la ve esta vez,
pero el ornitorrinco debe estar alerta.
Dos machos también ocupan esta area y,
muy pronto,
empezaran a competir por su afecto.
Cada uno tiene espolones en sus patas con
un fuerte veneno como el de las víboras.
Los machos pelean entre si y cortejan
a la hembra por varias semanas,
nadando cerca de ella,
y ocasionalmente mordiendo su cola.
Eventualmente, ella hace lo mismo,
y ellos nadan en círculos
antes de hacer el acto.
El macho ornitorrinco tiene un pene
con características excéntricas
como dos cabezas y espinas
que ayudan a la fertilización.
Tras la siguiente semana,
la hembra construye una extensa madriguera
amueblada con un cómodo nido.
Ella tapa los túneles que llevan al lugar,
haciéndolos ver como puntos muertos
para potenciales depredadores.
Entonces, como un reptil o como un ave,
ella deja los huevos desde su cloaca,
una simple entrada que es usada para la
reproducción y excreción.
Ella encuba sus huevos, y a medida que
el eucalipto rojo florece,
su descendencia nace.
Como otros mamíferos, les da leche.
Pero a diferencia de otros mamíferos,
no tiene pezones.
En lugar de pezones, su leche sale
de unas glándulas mamarias en su vientre,
donde sus bebes la sorben.
Esta leche almacenada atrae bacterias,
pero el ornitorrinco también produce
una potente proteína antibacterial,
asegurando que sus recién nacidos
estén a salvo.
Ella continua cuidándolos
por cuatro meses—
caza, evade a los zorros,
y repara su madriguera al mismo tiempo.
Hasta que sus bebes estén listos para
hacer su debut,
el verano esta terminando.
Una tarde, cuando la hembra ornitorrinco
regrese de cazar,
se dará cuenta que un polluelo ya habrá
dejado el nido.
Unos días después, el otro también
dejara el nido.
Pronto, sus bebes estarán viviendo
completamente independientemente.
Y eventualmente, ellos dejaran esta parte
del río para hacer sus propios hogares.